a mandarle un reporte en el cual se
menciona que el 49% de los maestros en
eeuu son miembros de algún sindicato
ella quiere verificar si esto se cumple
para los maestros en su estado para lo
cual va a tomar una muestra aleatoria de
estos maestros para ver qué porcentaje
de ellos son miembros de algún sindicato
sea p la proporción de maestros en su
estado que son miembros de algún
sindicato establece las hipótesis
adecuadas para su prueba de
significancia así que pausa el vídeo y
ve si lo puedes hacer hagámoslo juntos
lo que necesitamos hacer para esta
prueba de significancia es establecer
una hipótesis nula y una hipótesis
alternativa ahora tu hipótesis nula es
aquella en la que no hay cambio es lo
que esperarías que ocurriera así que al
leer el reporte te enteras de que el 49%
de los maestros en eeuu son miembros de
algún sindicato entonces es razonable
establecer que la hipótesis nula la
hipótesis de no cambio
el mismo porcentaje de maestros en su
estado son miembros de algún sindicato
esa proporción es p así que la hipótesis
nula es que la proporción en su estado
también es 49% ahora cuál sería entonces
la alternativa la alternativa es que la
proporción en su estado no es 49% aquí
tenemos lo que sería interesante
reportar que sucede algo diferente en su
estado cómo va a usar esto ella va a
tomar una muestra de maestros en su
estado va a calcular la proporción
muestral calcular la probabilidad de
obtener esa proporción muestral
suponiendo que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera si esa probabilidad es menor
que un cierto umbral que deberíamos
haber establecido de antemano el nivel
de significancia entonces ella rechazará
la hipótesis nula lo que sugeriría la
alternativa hagamos otro ejemplo
de acuerdo a una gran encuesta realizada
en 2015 alrededor del 90% de los hogares
en california tenía acceso a internet
investigadores de mercado quieren probar
si actualmente está proporción es mayor
para lo cual toman una muestra aleatoria
de mil hogares en california encontrando
que 920 un 92 por ciento de los hogares
muestreados tienen acceso a internet sea
p la proporción de hogares en california
que tienen acceso a internet establece
las hipótesis adecuadas para su prueba
de significancia de nueva cuenta pausa
el vídeo y ve si lo puedes resolver así
que nuevamente queremos establecer una
hipótesis nula y una hipótesis
alternativa
la hipótesis nula es la que considera
que no hay ningún cambio y se mantiene
el status quo es decir que la proporción
de personas que cuentan con internet
sigue siendo el que se reporta en el
último estudio continúa haciendo 90 por
ciento puedo escribir lo como 90 por
ciento
o como 0.9 ahora quizá algunos de
ustedes estuvieron tentados a poner 92 %
ahí es muy importante darse cuenta que
el 92 por ciento es la proporción
muestral es un estadístico de la muestra
cuando establecemos las hipótesis de la
prueba estas hipótesis se establecen en
relación al valor real del parámetro
cuál es el valor real de la proporción
de hogares en california que actualmente
cuentan con internet así que esto tiene
que ver con la proporción real entonces
la hipótesis alternativa es que ahora es
mayor que 90% lo cual puede escribir
como 0.9 por lo visto en esta pregunta
escribieron esto para distraerte para
hacerte pensar que tenías que incorporar
de alguna manera 92% de nueva cuenta
cómo se van a usar estas hipótesis
tomaron esta muestra para la cual
encontraron que el 92% de los hogares
tenía acceso a internet así que esta de
aquí es la proporción muestral para
calcular cuál es la probabilidad de esta
proporción muestral para este tamaño de
la muestra
la hipótesis nula es verdadera si dicha
probabilidad es menor que cierto umbral
menor que alfa el nivel de significancia
entonces se sugiere la alternativa nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo